what's going on everyone happy tuesday
hope you guys are pumped
uh for today's podcast slash video uh
i've been looking forward to this one
for a little bit and uh if i sound a
little bit stuffed up it's because i
have two massive tubes that are like
four inches long in each of my nostrils
uh but that was no reason to not give
you guys some sick
stuff uh for business stuff and this is
mostly just for me too
so uh anyways buckle up hope you enjoy
so today what i want to talk about is
the perfect business
and so believe it or not this is
actually something i talk a lot about um
not
as much publicly but what i like if if
we were to talk in person and talk
talk shop about business i i love
talking about business models i love
talking about
uh just monetization structures in
general uh writing books specifically
modification structures
uh so really excited about it but uh i
just recently finished
uh berkshire hathaway university which
is basically uh
uh the consolidated 30 years of
shareholder
uh the the war buffett a trolley bugger
the the you know the co-founders coach
sheriffs etc of
of berkshire hathaway they do these
yearly shareholder events and these guys
are both billionaires now they're both
in their
high 90s which is crazy they've been
investing for 50 plus years investing
for 50 plus years
and they've built a you know kajillion
dollar empire um i think as of today
it's worth half a trillion
um which is just nuts their return on
capital
was 2 million percent so when they
started where they when they acquired
berkshire hathaway which was a publicly
traded company at the time was a textile
company
they uh the stock was nineteen dollars i
believe
actually no they offered to buy war buff
it out at eleven dollars and thirty
cents
uh i love fifty anyways doesn't matter
point is is that it was it was between
11 and 20 right and
at this point that same stock is worth
377
000 all right so that's a that's a 20
000 x return so if you so his odd put
thousand dollars in it's not worth 200
million all right
that's how crazy this is and over you
know 30 years of shareholder things
there's many times where he gives little
nuggets of wisdom of what he's looking
at
uh when he's buying a business or what
he what he believes to be valuable
businesses
and uh i was really it was cool for me
because uh i have always had
three main things that i look for
businesses and in reading his book
or the book that was about his
shareholder readings i added two
uh two to that list and so i wanted to
share those with you
today all right and uh the moniker that
i have
had for this is i'm gonna i'm gonna
share with you
is unique
expensive
sticky air
and i said there's five there's four
words here that's okay because i'm going
to show the last one in a second
but unique expensive sticky air so what
i'm looking for like in my mind of what
a perfect
business is it's unique expensive sticky
here and i've explained each one of
these
so unique is something uh and i'll even
tell you one of the things that he said
in his shareholder video that i found
really just it was just so it was so
short and so like packed that i loved it
um he said in response to what is an
ideal business in one of the one of the
meetings he said
uh something that costs a penny sells
for a buck
it is habit-forming and it was so
succinct it's so great and
reading some of the other stuff he's got
other other things but that one was
three of the five in three sentences
right so
they cost a penny sells for a dollar and
it's habit for me
and i just like it it's just so great
all right so let's let's break this down
so something that costs a penny so that
would be like air
something that costs you almost nothing
to make all right
it's expensive meaning you could sell it
for a dollar so
cost you a penny you could sell it for a
dollar and it's
sticky it's habit for me people come
back and keep buying it again
and again and again right which means
very long lifetime values
all right that's that's what he's
looking at initially now
the the unique part is something that if
you if you listen to some of his other
stuff
is he likes to have big competitive
boats all right so what's something
that's
you know what's how can i find air for a
petty sell it for a dollar that people
come back you want to keep breathing
and no one else can sell it so it's
unique air
right it's not here that anyone can sell
it's specific to the
to it has a brand behind it that no one
could copy uh it has
share of mind he talks about that a lot
uh like geico
everyone here probably does like you
could say 50 or more by switching to
geico you've heard that
uh because he 10x their advertising
budget as soon as he bought the whole
thing
uh and just had them go on a massive
rampage so they could take over my chair
and
geico has grown proportionately and so
this is four of those features right
unique expensive sticky air something
equal
make for a petty sells for a dollar is
habit forming that no one
else can replicate and um
for me this is just so cool uh and i'll
talk about a couple of the features of
this in a second
um you know what i'll talk about it now
so one thing that you'll notice and this
is for all the newer entrepreneurs or
you know really
[ __ ] it any entrepreneur uh who's
interested in this kind of thing
notice the gross margins he's talking
about right a lot of people quote
feel bad for charging for things that
don't cost that much which is a terrible
mindset to have
you charge what the market will give you
right so if
for example uh you you know you find
this
these widgets like these pens and you
know that that you get them from some
place in china that cost you a dollar if
someone's willing to give you a hundred
dollars for it
do you feel bad taking it
you're like well if only they do markets
are built
on information advantages information
inefficiencies meeting one person the
seller knows more than the buyer
that's that's how these things work a
lot right
and so uh i i noticed this because you
know you're
listening to one of the best investors
of all time if not the best investor of
all time
and he looks for like a hundred to one
right costs a penny sells for a dollar
a hundred to one it costs one penny one
percent cost of goods
compared to what it's being sold for so
99 gross margins
that for me was actually very very
interesting
uh is that he he doesn't go for like an
80 or a 90
he goes for 99 and for perspective
the difference between selling something
uh for a dollar that cost you 10 cents
versus selling something for a dollar
that costs you penny is not
that uh you know it's it's just nine
percent more profitable to sell some you
know
sell it for a dollar that costs a penny
versus a dollar that costs a dime
it's actually ten times more profitable
and here's here's why i better explain
this
is that for one unit of cost
the petty one could sell 10 times the
amount for that one cost
so does that make sense so if i were to
sell 10 pennies worth of buy cost it
means i make 10
whereas 10 pennies worth of the other
example of a dive is only one dollar
and that's one of the things that people
don't understand about margins right
the gross margin of the product that you
have like every increment when you go
from when you go from 90 to 95
gross margins in a business you double
the profitability of the business
that's what's crazy right and so uh
that's why this is so important
right now if you try for example look at
your prices right now
and say uh i want to get to if you're at
90 and you say i want to get to 95
percent gross margins
now let's say it costs you right uh
let's say it costs you 10 right uh
for your for your thing right you sell
for a hundred that's ninety percent
gross margin so ninety dollars is
is margin for you ten dollars is cost
you sell for a hundred all right
so if you wanted to get to 95 percent
gross margins
what do you think you do would you add
five dollars maybe 105
no that's not bad to get to 95 gross
margins
you'd have to sell the same 10 thing for
200
that's what people don't get about
margins right and so what i
like what i would we would we would turn
gyms around at what and whatnot i would
have guys who are at 66
margins that's usually where most people
are and that's horrible by the way
and i would say we need to get you to
80. and they would see 66 to 80.
only 14 percent only 14 you just saw me
double the price from 100 to 200 to get
five
right and so that's that's how important
these margins are
and so to hear this man say i want
something that i could
create for a penny sell for a dollar
that's habit for me get people keep
buying over and over again for the rest
of their lives
and that no one else can buy because
it's unique right
that was pretty cool and so these are
the four kind of components of the
business itself
but the last thing that buffett talks
about and he talks about this a lot
so i draw a little dotted line here
is the person who is running it all
right and he has three characteristics
that i saw him repeat over and over
again
uh for the management or the operators
all right and they have such a brilliant
model of managing
right because berkshire only has like 19
employees or something like that
something stupid and they have
a gazillion they did 88 billion in
profits last year
think about that 88 billion the second
most profit in the entire world
was like a 20-person company because
they're so good at advocating response
just basically delegating
out responsibility to the businesses
that they bought now
he turns out a lot of deals but what he
looks for in operators and this is why i
think this is cool
is that what he looks for in operators
we can look for it ourselves we could
create that
ourselves as entrepreneurs right we
could think how can i embody these
characteristics
all right and so the first of these
characteristics
is he says i want somebody who's risk
averse all right
because he said many times any things
time zero is zero he's like you could
have 30 years of a great track record
and make one bet that goes to zero and
lose it all
and that is why he's so risk-averse and
i had a mentor who told me something
once that i
that i just loved he said alex you
should only have to get rich once
and for some reason that just like that
that hit different you should only have
to get rich once
and so uh and the smartest best of the
world feels that way too
you should be risk averse he's like i
give i give up bigger opportunities
all day long to to cover my downside
all right the richest people in the
world i'm telling you this right now if
you don't have access to people who are
worth a hundred million a billion i do
and i will tell you how they think all
right
it's all about downside risk mitigation
they will give up
they will give up huge returns to not
risk
losing money and the funny thing is that
poor people think the exact opposite
they go for the lottery
they've basically 100 guaranteed
downside
right one in 300 million of winning and
they do it all the time
right and one of the things that uh buff
says is like if you if you
uh if you bet poorly small you'll bet
poorly big
uh which i i love that too right so
anyways number one matchmaker is
risk-averse so we think about ourselves
how can i be more risk-averse how can i
make sure that i can't lose
right it's much more important to not
lose than it is to win and what's
interesting is that if you don't lose
long enough you kind of win by default
which is kind of interesting which
brings me to the second point which is
log-term thinking so the reason that
they like
family-owned business specifically is
that families
think about generations they think about
passing it down between
you know father and son parents and kids
right
and they like those businesses because
they don't cut quarters they think about
quality they think about long-term
investment long-term competitive
strategy they're not thinking about
quarterly earnings and you know
basically short-term gratification
which is what most of the stock market
companies are forced to do
because they have to pay her to to to
stock
stockholders right and so if you can't
i've talked about this
some of my other podcasts shifting from
ceo to investor but one of the most
beneficial things that i have done for
my mental health and for the success of
my business
is thinking in a long-term type horizon
and i can't tell you that
i'll tell you that of the people that i
encounter the longer their time horizon
that they talk in
the wealthier more successful they are
invariably
so when i talk to somebody and all
they're thinking about is this week the
next two weeks payroll and what they're
gonna make this month and last month
i already know that they don't make a
ton right
and it's because that's all they think
in right and then and then they get from
there you get to
slightly higher level entrepreneurs
they're thinking in quarters okay
this quarter this one we can't focus
anything this chord is all we got this
is what we can do right and that's fine
because the smaller you are the less
stable you are it's more volatile right
but over time as you expand those
horizons right
you'll be able to make better better
decisions because you'll start thinking
well if i did this for five straight
years would it be reasonable that i
would win
probably right uh if i do this
consistently for five years do i think
that i will
it would be unreasonable that i won't be
able to be far past by my my goal
probably right but most people still
think of these tiny chunks of time and
could never get ahead
and they spend month after month after
month for 30 years trying to become
millionaires
rather than just set a goal of like well
let me just see if i could increase my
my income by 20 000 in the next year
right and then next year after that i'll
try and increase it by another 20 000
and they do that by you know and in five
years you have a top one percent income
uh but only 99 of people
don't think that way which is why only
one percent do so anyways
number one for the management is that
they're risk averse they will take they
will take the loss
they will not take the opportunity to
avoid the loss number two they think of
long term horizons
right and number three
they have unimpeachable character
which i just really like that is a word
unimpeachable
character and
if he uh if you listen to or talk about
uh
about about about losing buddy he said
if you lose money that will be forgiven
he said but if you lose me a shred of
reputation i will be ruthless
and he's he's so uh so big on this
and i think that's you know these these
these kind of three things come together
people who have unimpeachable character
are not trying to get rich quick right
they're trying to build something of
value they're trying to build something
that's enduring something that's
long term and uh
they're honest and so what happens
though is that when you have an
impeachable character it's actually
intangible that has compounding returns
and
i'll explain what would be that but he
talks about it for his own business he's
like the fact that
our check's always clear that we we do
what we say we're going to do
uh allow us to get access to more deals
because more people want to work with us
right
and we do we close deals faster and so
the thing is is that your reputation
over time becomes a competitive
advantage
and that's what a what's a unique that's
a sustainable and compounding
competitive advantage
because someone who's stuck with their
word for 10 years compared to somebody
stuck with their word for 30 years whose
word is worth more
the 30-year guy someone she's stuck with
you know who's done everything and but
unique character for 30 years compared
to guys done it for 60 years
who has the stronger word the 60-year
guy it's something that if you can
develop it literally compounds with time
uh and it's and it's in his opinion
priceless and i think he's a very good
valuer of things
and so anyways the perfect business
model i'll give you a quick recap
it's unique expensive sticky year that's
managed
by somebody who's risk averse long-term
thinking and has unimpeachable character
all right so something that you could
create for a penny sell for a buck
that's habit-forming that no one else
can do and
you do it in such a way that you don't
take short-term risks
you think long-term in terms of how
you're going to invest in the business
and the legacy
and building something of value and not
not obsessed with short-term volatility
but for a long-term earning
and finally that you do it in such a way
that people will think
everything that this man has done has
been fairly earned and wisely used
and so with that i will leave you with
the perfect business i hope you enjoyed
this hope you found this valuable this
is one of my favorite
things to talk about and uh keep being
awesome and if you're in the arena
keep getting up i promise uh you will
get better over time
lots of love i'll catch you guys soon
bye